We're talking to Nick Offerman,
whose new show is called The Great North.
It's an adult comedy, it's on Fox.
Cannot wait, so excited.
Nick, I love your opinions on things,
and we're gonna play a little game called Sound Offerman.
(bugle blaring)
(crowd clapping)
(Drew laughing)
Okay.
I'm going to throw out some topics
and you'll tell us how you feel about them.
You'll sound off for me.
Okay, I think I can do this game.
Okay, I can't wait.
All right, voice texts,
when you record audio of yourself talking
and text it to someone are so hot right now,
everyone's doing it.
Are you doing it?
I didn't realize that it was a hot trend,
but I strongly approve.
I've been doing it for years because I live in Los Angeles,
where you spend five eighths of your life in your car,
and so I'm driving, I can't text, 'cause I want to be safe
and live to see tomorrow, so I go for the voice text,
and say, "Hey dad, it's Nick,
"I'm sending you this because I'm driving.
"Don't forget to bring the nightcrawlers.
"We will have fun fishing.
"I love you, goodbye."
It's okay to say I love you to other men.
It's 2021.
(all clapping)
Sound Offerman.
Yes, that is sound offering and dropping the mic.
Okay, this one's personal.
Saying a friendly hello to strangers, but they ignore you.
Does that ruffle your feathers?
Funny you should ask, Drew.
When I go running, which I regularly do
in the Hills of Hollywood, because I'm from the Midwest,
I immediately began to wave to people and greet them.
And I would say, only about half the people
will like clock me and respond,
and often I really enjoy the response,
'cause it has a sense of,
"Oh, I remember this, this is neighborliness."
Yeah.
"I forgot about this.
"Isn't this from like the eighties?"
And the other half, now, some of them,
I'm a, middle-aged white guy, sometimes I have a big beard,
so, I'd say 15% of the women in a certain age group
are probably right to ignore me,
because that's a scary scenario.
(Drew laughs)
But by and large, there's this weird thing, I think,
in our society where we have let go of the need
to be social and recognize one another.
There's also people will be out walking when I'm running,
and they're walking down the street
just full on-
Yeah.
And I'll be like, "Hello."
And they just don't, they can't even,
their attention doesn't waver from their device.
I'm constantly thinking about the moment,
the idea, and the fact that we all went from this to this.
And you know what, Drew?
I think they're related.
I think that our sensibility that important things
happen inside here, and then the world is virtual,
that's what I need to worry about.
So if somebody is over there,
a real person is like, "Hey,"
that's not part of the matrix that I've signed up for.
Yes.
And so I think those things are related.
And I think that you might find that the human being
actually is more infinitely entertaining,
and organic, and unique, and inspiring
than any app you could ever play, except for Candy Crush.
Yeah.
(crowd laughs)
And I have to admit I do love a good GPS,
and I love a good Shazam,
but I think what you just said is really profound,
and I love it.
I'm going to be thinking about it a lot, so thank you.
Well, I love sound offermaning with you,
and I just think you're so awesome.
And I love your wife so much,
and my greatest love and affection to the both of you.
And may we all find ourselves in some toga gear
as soon as possible.
That would be a nice full circle moment.
So thank you so much for coming here today, Nick.
Amen to that, Drew.
Thank you so much.
It's great to see you.
Well, be sure to catch The Great North
Sundays at 8:30 PM on Fox,
the new fantastic animated adult show.
We need these shows, they're fantastic,
and so are you, Nick.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)
(singers humming)